[Music]
Hey SSI t can you send somebody over
no kitty knock and here that was wanted
I heard you were having a hard time with
your hard drive it's where did I
literally just called a second ago I'm
pretty fast but when things get hot and
sticky I know I take things slowly plus
I like to make sure my clients get their
full bang for their buck this is free
right because this is a company laptop
you you work for the company and I do
indeed so where's my naughty little
patient well this is it as you can see
it's it's it's not three it's not doing
anything Shh yourself mine it's not like
it's the apocalypse
after all no what seems to be the
problem baby tell me was running into
Yuki didn't you need to tell me smell
for me well I guess I'm worried that I
might have downloaded a virus what what
you oh whoa whoa are you telling me that
you didn't use protection when you touch
this fine piece of equipment I'm sure
there's some kind of protection software
on there man oh you're sure you're sure
so it's hard responsibility to bring
protection to the party you're a piece
of villains think it's can you wake
up my hair and I'm not the piece of
you're the one that's talking seems like
a sex toy please please don't interrupt
I'm working here what are you doing I'm
liking the cameraman she's telling me
that you never loved her that you never
touched her in the right way that you
you never touched her at all really
never really thought about our needs
okay so true you need to create a mug
okay are you actually gonna do anything
you're just gonna talk to it ah I'm
gonna do something I know what you need
and I'm gonna give her what she eats for
this might be difficult for you to watch
though if you can fix that just fix it
that's okay okay baby tell me what you
like
oh oh okay okay
yeah okay I'm gonna give you to your
little tip when you're on your own okay
a lot of guys or go with the same old
see more that's control-alt-delete but
I'm going to introduce you to your
little move it's a little bit more
sophisticated it's called the Mac attack
Oh looks like I just had this bot yeah
oh oh okay okay can I see your ID again
then I oh okay maybe just get out of
here man
don't you interrupt me we're nearly
there baby come you're ruining my blade
man you're ruining my fight nearly that
nearly nearly there oh oh my god that's
I can't be good for the computer man oh
oh all this this is just a pleasure in
its free of charge
okay now you're gonna take care of her
okay and if you guys need me
you got my details man I am Thank You
Chicago I won't be using this
you
[Music]